the first time i saw the queen met the
queen
um
that i
remember properly as it were
was in
liverpool
during the capital cultural year
european capital culture in 2008
when i was dean of the cathedral looking
after the anglican cathedral there
and she came on a visit during that year
and
it was an extraordinary moment
um they were just opening reopening the
whole city center liverpool one that was
the
the purpose of her coming
and there was a great
uh reception somewhere
and
i just remember
there was a rwandan
woman who had survived the genocide
and was in exile as an asylum seeker
refugee in india
very remarkable woman
and
uh
she was put at the queen's table
and at the end of lunch when everyone
else was going off the queen spent it
must have been 15-20 minutes
just sitting with her and talking to her
she gave that completely unimportant
woman unimportant in inverted comments
um
this absolute focus
and i i
it was something she never forgot the
the woman never got
i knew her and the healing impact that
had on her was quite extraordinary
and would that be your
fondest memory or do you have others oh
no i think there's a lot of fond
memories i can't think of any unfond
memories
um
i think
seeing her
after the funeral of the duke of
edinburgh that extraordinary remember
that
absolutely mesmerizing photograph of her
by herself
at the end of that service
she was meant to go back up
to her apartments in
in a car
but she noticed that
among the very few guests
were some
german relatives
who had come across prince and
princesses who'd come across
about four of them
for the funeral
and she
very firmly
didn't get into the car but went into
the cloisters of st george's chapel and
bison george's chapel
and talked to them
in order to make them feel properly
welcomed and appreciated
and i think that that
that's another one that's very typical
of her
um
and then the first time i preached in
front of her
uh but were you nervous
terrifying
it was in
westminster abbey
and it was the
50th
no 60th anniversary of the
coronation as opposed to the accession
so
ten years
nine years ago
and uh i've been impressed about six
weeks
and i
preached this sermon
[Music]
and then we had lunch together i was at
the lunch and i was on her right
uh in
jerusalem chamber or
at the abbey and
i didn't realize what the rules were at
that point so i was on her right and at
the beginning of the meal she turned to
talk to the dean of westminster on her
left
and
i i thought what have i said
you know turned
quite away from me oh
and
of course
there's a pressure cooker for it so
as soon as the main course came that was
the first call she turned to me
and
i had then you know she was talking to
me for the whole of the main course and
then she turned back and then she said
yeah it's they turn each course as it
were you turn one side then the other
and to make sure you talk to people on
both sides and i think those stories
it somehow sums up her
extraordinary level of courtesy but her
lack of
self-importance
everyone gets treated equally
nobody is more important
so
a rwandan
refugee gets
absolutely undivided attention
it was very amazing
how do you think
she has coped uh with the loss of the
duke who was by her side for 72 years
i honestly don't know i think there are
very few people who do
very properly
i think there
that she opens her heart to
only people who've been alongside her
for
years and years and years and years and
years
and they won't breathe a word
which is why they stay alongside her
um
i think
like many you've met her from
time to time
i think what you see
is courage
but also a complete lack of self-pity
and that means she doesn't
she feels grief but she's it's
as she said on one occasion it's not
about me
something that characterized the duke as
well
and um
therefore
she
is able
in an extraordinary way to
go on
with this huge gap in her life with just
total courage
given events that you've seen over the
last couple of days or so that have been
reported on and then you talked about
the queen's the prince's funeral her
stoicism
all the more exemplary
i don't
think there's anyone
in the country
who
would disagree
with
the idea that her stoicism
her
example
to the country
is flawless
in so many regards
you have to be quite warped
not to look at that photograph
and feel
that there is someone
who does what is right whatever it costs
and that's extraordinary
i wish there were more of us and i
include myself
who had
quite that sense of just going to do the
right thing what can you tell me about
the service of thanksgiving the service
of thanksgiving
is
um
has
distinct echoes of the
coronation
in terms of some of the music
but he's also forward looking
[Music]
it is in no sense
maudlin and nostalgic
it has a distinct forward-looking
deeply christian-based
faithful
hope for the future
i think it's
a service that if we allow
ourselves will have a massively uniting
impact on the country
justin archbishop your grace thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you much appreciated thank you